[Music]
leave
right now
the guy in the gray hoodie is robbing
the bank who's in charge here well she
is but we're both i'm and i'm the
manager
estelle valerie
still um once they leave
you lock the front of back doors you
understand me you lock them all
got the fbi the gbi everybody here
[Music]
i'm sorry okay this is sergeant bernard
is everyone all right in there as long
as everybody stays calm nobody gets hurt
i have a bomb and i'm gonna kill myself
and everybody in here my commands and
i'm there
hey there this is the windy hills wells
fargo
uh
yes ma'am this is the wells fargo
uh yeah i need to talk to bridget about
my 401k i think she made a nine thousand
dollar mistake i'm sorry to hear that
man can i take a message for you
fraud was committed the va stole my
disability check from me
i've had some problems with veteran
affairs myself how about you release one
of those ladies no
i need everybody to see what's happening
here i need the fire trucks i need the
news cameras you have my undivided
attention
[Music]
gonna work this out brother brother i do
not have as much time as you think i do
snipers are in place come at you come
and do
[Music]
what do i need to do to get the
attention that i need right now
everything you say
everything you do
it matters
you matter
all you got to do now is just make good
right
[Music]
just make good
you ever been robbed before once
[Music]
you